[Music]
oh i didn't see you there
hi everybody and welcome back to our pi
data sponsor interviews
today i'm joined by max bach from ing
he's going to tell us a little bit about
how
ing uses open source tools from the pi
data ecosystem
he's going to tell us a little bit about
why ing is such a big contributor
to the pi data community both
at the meetup level with hosting meetups
like pi data amsterdam
and also at the conference level as a
long time host of pi data amsterdam
conference so max could you introduce
yourself to the pi data global audience
yes thanks yeah i am
i'm matt bark i'm i'm 42 years old
um i am what is called chapter lead data
science
at uh ing bank in the wholesale banking
advance analytics department
chapter elite is uh it's it's
essentially the same title as
chief data scientist um
i've been working there since 2019 uh
i have a long background actually in uh
science i used to work in high energy
particle physics
for for 13 years um
i worked at uh at slack at stanford and
also long time at cern in geneva
looking for the the expo particle for
example
and in 2015 i switched to
the the industry and i became a data
scientist
and i started working at a as chief data
scientist at kpmg in the netherlands
doing big data and advanced analytics
and so since 2019 i work at
ing bank
max would you like to also introduce
your team at ing
sure yeah so i like i said i work at
wholesale banking advanced analytics
wholesale banking stands for
large corporate clients at the bank
and advanced analytics we fall under
innovation
we have about 100 people inside
our team and we make uh
ai products and of these hundred people
a lot of different people data engineers
software developers ux
product owners these type of things but
also a lot of data scientists about we
have about 17
um data scientists and
so i'm one of the two managers managing
these data scientists
and we work on quite a few different
projects very diverse
so max tell me a little bit about the
open source tools that you use
at ing yes so
we use a lot of them we essentially we
use
uh all tools that that help us to get
the job done
and of course we rely heavily on uh
on many of the non-focus uh
tools at pandas numpy sci-fi
um etc um
and uh uh many uh
you know we're doing i'm a data
scientist we're doing
we're doing a lot of exploratory data
analysis building models
so we use a lot of things like
second learn
[Music]
by torch tensorflow whatever library is
out there that
is useful for us that is well supported
clearly and is known
yeah as well you know uh that has
features that we that we can use
functionality that we can use
what recent developments in open source
tools have gotten you the most excited
yes that's a good question um i
i it's related to essentially
what i would say are the biggest pain
points
that we have at uh at least in my team
and at ing
we have a very nice data analytics
platform uh
and it's called dap data analytics
platform that's maintained by a lot of
data engineers software developers and
it's really great so it's
completely built on top of open source
uh
tooling so it runs kubernetes
to your lab that everyone uses a lot of
different
database types that you can use via
spark etc
it's really nice for uh doing data
exploration
uh developing models but what i find
a bit hard is uh actually maintaining
models that are running in production
and so it's it's a little bit but it's
out of sight
and you've built something and it's
running it's out of sight
can be for all sorts of reasons that
things break down or maybe the date is
changing over time
so i'm actually quite excited about uh
tooling these days that there's been a
lot of development
in tooling that where
they allow you to manage models properly
that are running in production
and also managed models that you are
experimenting with
so things think about tools like uh ml
flow
but also uh it's like more like machine
learning engineering tools that allow
you to do
the plumbing as i call it um
to make sure that it makes it to make it
really easy to put things into
production
and also to maintain it over time and to
monitor it over time
so i can i can ascertain that you are
actually quite excited about tools that
help you productionize your machine
learning models
but what further development would you
like to see
out of the open source ecosystem of
machine learning tools
things which you think aren't quite
there yet and
may need some further refinement or
further development
last year me and and a few colleagues we
we built a library that we actually also
open sourced and we did that
specifically because we thought
we didn't see anything good didn't see
any good open source tooling out there
that could do that
which is actually um
to monitor for population shift
over time so when your data is changing
over time and this is this
think of it as data that's being fed
into models that are used to make
predictions
for example you work at a you work at a
bank uh you can imagine there are a lot
of loan applications
just give an example and you predict uh
will this person be able to
pay back his or her loan if you train
your data on a certain
uh historical data set and you then
start to apply it on new data that's
coming in but the data is changing over
time
then are the predictions still reliable
is or is the model that you're using is
still performing optimally
and to do monitoring of incoming data
and predictions over time
there is commercial software out there
we've been looking at open source
code but i didn't see much good out
there
so we actually we actually wrote
something ourselves we also open sourced
this
um there i'm yeah
i think we need more when it comes to
model management
so in your own work you've decided to
open source projects that you have
initiated
on your team yes what
convinced you to open source these tools
what drove you to make these tools open
source rather than keep them
internal and proprietary yes
we yeah various reasons of course we're
excited
to share our knowledge and whatever we
are doing
um i have a long background as a
scientist
where yeah with what we always did was
you know
we we we would always share you know
we'll publish we would share our work
because it's like second nature to me
and of course it's it's much more
exciting to
uh yeah to make your work and your
knowledge available to others just like
it's very useful we can use that
knowledge
by others and the other thing is that i
am convinced that
by open sourcing uh your code
and by actually getting all the details
around me because you need to get
a lot of details right before you want
to open source it it needs to be
properly documented the code quality
needs to be good
you're actually raising the standards of
your work
and also you're raising the standard of
the work in your team
do you or your team contribute back to
any community driven open source
projects we do
uh not not as much it's usually on an
individual level so we use packages
maybe there are bugs
yeah we will we will submit merge
requests if there's stuff not not
working
but when it comes to like the bigger
packages like in non-focus
let's say you want to get something
committed to pandas
yeah actually my one of my bosses did
that a couple months ago and he had like
100
100 comments that he had to go through
so that could actually be quite a bit of
work but in general we do
not so much but yes we do
did you feel like there was any barrier
or any hurdle that you had to
cross to even convince people to
contribute back in the form of just bug
fixes to existing projects
or did that come to you and to your team
very naturally
in my team it's very natural if you rig
it up i will always say yeah yes go
ahead
go and do it
and that's no question no question about
it
if you wanted to speak to a colleague at
another organization similar to yours
and convince them to upstream their
changes to open source projects or to
just
contribute back what would you tell them
i think
uh yeah i would just say go for it do it
you use it so give back to the community
yeah
stands for reason i would say
i think i think it comes natural for a
lot of data scientists to be honest
um maybe some of them are a bit shy if
their coding standards are not that good
and uh yeah sometimes with bigger more
popular packages you do see that there
are a lot of requirements you need to
fulfill
before uh before
making pull before making words requests
pull requests um
but uh yeah i i also see that when
people do
have a pull request that's accepted
they're actually pretty proud so
yeah go for it do you think that
contributing back to open source is
something that might make
a future colleague on your team excited
about joining you
in at ing yes because um
i see that uh people who are
joining joining my team during other
advanced analytics teams
it's something that they really
appreciate they can work on
on those type of things yes they like it
was it hard for you to convince your
co-workers to
use img office space to sponsor the pi
data amsterdam meetup
was it hard for you to convince your
co-workers to contribute back to the pi
data amsterdam conference
uh general no no it's relatively easy
the um there's an ing
is a i would say it's a data-driven bank
and there's a lot of they underst they
understand
that to get good people um
you need to support these these
community efforts and you need to show
your face
uh at such community efforts so actually
was
it quite easy quite easy to uh
to get support for this how do you see
that ing benefits from supporting
the pi data amsterdam meetup the pi data
amsterdam conference
or the pie data community in general i
would say two things on the one and uh
it shows to the
the community here in here in amsterdam
that
we are an active player in the field of
data science
and so that we are an interesting place
to work
and so it's a good way for us to attract
uh to attract potential new people
and uh the other thing is that yeah it's
it's a very nice platform
for people to present their work they
really like it when
you know if they've they could have
spent half a year or maybe a year
on building a really good model and of
course you know working at a bank you
can't
say all the details but usually you can
say enough that you can still share all
the exciting
uh stuff and your learnings with an
audience
and so it's it's it's good for them
i think it's a very good skill to learn
and this is having a podium for this is
really good
how does contributing back to the pi
data amsterdam community help
you specifically yes well
it's of course it's nice to get to know
other people
that's good but uh one important reason
for me
uh like i said is also because i'm a
managers of data scientists as well
and to make them grow um
they need a podium where they can show
their their their thing so if they
if if they prepare themselves you know
make a good presentation
and people are excited i'm also excited
what is your favorite open source tool
you know the introduction of
notebooks jupiter notebook has really um
yeah made doing data science and
exploratory data analysis has
made things so much easier so
clearly i use i use a lot of tools but
i'm always using them in jupyter
notebooks
and before i you know if i've written
code before
porting it to actually uh
before i writing an actual library out
of it but uh yeah i'm always falling
back on your notebooks
how has jupiter hub changed your life
professionally
yeah it's made things a lot easier also
sharing results with your colleagues
is a lot easier you shared a notebook
please run it again
same with um yeah docker for example
if you use the same docker images
everything is consistent you can
reproduce
results bugs these type of things
i think in that way it's made life
easier
how has the proliferation of high
quality open source tools for machine
learning
change the nature of your work well
i would say professionally i would say
it's opened up
sort of a huge field of new work because
uh
you know with all these open source
tools that have become available both
for
sort of advanced doing advanced
analytics and big data
so i before i worked at ing i used to i
worked at ing
which is a consultancy firm
and we did projects for other companies
yeah uh investigating their data and uh
and uh sort of extracting insights from
the building models for them
and uh the fact that these two that's
only possible because
the these tools are around and you could
make it
it was very easy to set up like a new
cluster and you'd have your tools
available to start analyzing data within
no time essentially
so um yeah it's open it's in my
day-to-day work at ing bank
we use it all the time it's it's um
but also it's just made it so much
easier to start doing new projects
what does your team at ing do uh i've
there are multiple advanced analytics
teams at ing
we have about nine big ones
so i work in one of them i uh i'm what
is called a chapter lead data science
so it's not like a motorcycle game but
it's uh
it's uh i manage a team of data
scientists there are
17 data scientists in the 16 17 in the
team
two managers and we work on multiple
projects
uh which are very diverse
we follow under innovation a team is
called wholesale banking advanced lytics
we fall under innovation and we
essentially pick up anything that
that can can help the bank which could
be like
using nlp techniques to scan through big
loan documents
um we uh
it can be anti-money laundering efforts
uh
yeah it can be you know helping predict
uh currency prices these type of things
it's extremely diverse so you've been at
ing
since 2019 what made you
most excited to join your team at ing
yes a good question so before that
i did data science consultancy and those
were projects that typically lasted a
couple of months
and what i did work that i do now at ing
uh in this in my advanced analytics team
we really build products from a to z
and that typically takes longer than uh
than a couple of months
so we go from inception all the way to
users
using the product and getting their
feedback and improving things
and um yeah that that just takes a
longer time
so we actually have that we have the
time to make really good products
including advanced analytics models uh
which
uh which is what we do as data
scientists there
so that's that was uh that was a big
important reason for me to uh to start
working at ing and ideas yeah
i see that they're really committed to
doing data science good data science
and to use it to help the band
so is ing hiring data scientists
we are always looking for good people
and uh
yeah you can uh you can always reach out
yeah definitely
so max what would make a candidate
really stand out for you
it it can be can be multiple things
but they in general they need to impress
me
in some way or also the other other
people that i'm interfering with
it can be we usually make them do a test
can be that
they are performing really well at the
test they have a really original
solution
but it can also be that their background
knowledge
is really good or that their code
quality is really good
and we need to be there needs to be
something or it's really what they did a
really good
exploratory data analysis in their in
their exercise
and they really went they really went
deep um
and that yeah that needs to impress us
in some way if you get a lot of
applications
you need to stand out it's always it's
always a question to ask
how do you differentiate how are you
different from other data scientists
what are you really good at
max i understand one of your team
members is going to speak at pi data
global
are you excited to see their talk can
you tell us a little bit about what
they'll be speaking about
yes it's actually one of the people that
i work with closely
she's called lorraine del meda
she's a data scientist working in london
actually our team is spread out over
multiple places
and she will be talking about entity
matching
advanced entity matching at scale
i can introduce a topic shortly that we
we of course as a bank we have a lot of
transactions
coming in and going out for example
we're interested
in uh when you have outgoing
transactions we want to know if say the
names on those transactions if they can
actually
be connected to any known clients at ing
to get a better picture of a full
picture of a client
so that's actually a very
computationally difficult problem has a
lot of interesting data science angles
so we want to match names to node names
and it's
it's a big problem very interesting
please take a look
so max is there any final words you'd
like to leave with the pi data global
community
uh yes please go check out there are two
talks
by ing given it by data global please go
check them out they're very interesting
maybe also please check out the open
source contributions by ing
you can find them at githubgithub.com
ing bank
and please contribute to open source
thank you everybody for joining us
in this pi data global sponsor interview
with max bach from ing bank
it was really interesting hearing a
little bit about how ing bank uses these
open source tools
and i'm very happy to hear that ing is a
big supporter not only of our pi data
meetup and conferences but also of the
pi data ecosystem itself in the form of
making direct contributions back to the
projects
and originating their own open source
projects thanks max
thanks james much appreciated thank you
everybody for joining us
i'll see you all next time
[Music]
you